what ideas in the constitution or the
declaration of independence do you think
are
the most important to the success of the
united states of america i'll answer the
question but before answering the
question i want a dissent from
registered descent from iran's is it the
public education is it which uh no no
actually
we're we're not so look we're not so far
apart on on on public education i'm
actually kind of i'm actually kind of
surprised that you're so anti-bismarck
because his public school system was his
national public school system was
created in order to stick it to the
church
it was the church that ran the schools
before then and okay so that's a
different i'm also sticking it to the
church
you know where freedom is in education
okay so so um i i want to register a
dissent about uh lincoln look lincoln is
an important figure and a great man and
he was presiding over a country which at
that point was pretty jeffersonian in
terms of its uh self-perception he said
what he needed to say i'm not going to
criticize him but i don't accept the
idea that the the declaration of
independence which starts one revolution
is uh is of a peace with the
constitution the second constitution the
constitution of 1787 the nationalist
constitution which is effectively a
counter-revolution
what happens is there is a revolution
it's based on certain principles they're
a lot it not exactly but in many ways
resembles the the later
ideas of the french revolution and what
the federalist party does the national
nationalist conservative party does is a
counter-revolution to reinstate the old
english constitution so these documents
are
if you're willing to accept the evidence
of history they are in many respects
contrary to one another and uh so if if
i'm asked what's the most important
values that are handed down by these
documents i don't have an objection to
uh you know to uh life liberty and
property all of which are really
important things i do have an objection
to the the to the
pom-pom the pompous overreach of
uh these are self-evident which is
absurd they can't be self-evident if
they were self-evident then somebody
would have come up with them you know
like like 2000 years before it's not
it's not self-evident and and so so
that's damaging i i like the
conservative preamble of the
constitution
which uh describes the purposes of the
of the national government that's being
established there there are sev seven
purposes uh a more perfect union which
is the prince of the principle of
cohesion
justice
uh domestic peace uh common defense the
general welfare which is is uh the
welfare of the public as a as a thing
that's not only individuals but there is
such a thing as a general welfare
liberty which we agree is absolutely
crucial and posterity the idea that the
purpose of the government is to be able
to sustain and grow
this independent nation and not only to
guarantee rights no matter what happens
but you don't like the we hold these
truth to be self-evident so you're
definitely beatles guy you don't want
the you don't want the pompous
you don't need that right i look i i
just i think that that expression
self-evident truth
it does tremendous damage because it it
it
instead of a moderate skepticism which
says
look we may not know everything it says
look we know everything here it is
here's what we know we know we don't
know everything no we
so you know i'll agree with you i don't
like self-evident i don't like
self-evident because he's absolutely
right it's not self-evident these are
massive achievements
these are massive achievements of of of
enlightened thinking of studying history
of understanding human nature of
deriving a truth from
3 000 years of star of historical
knowledge and a better understanding of
human nature and and and capacity it's
using reason in some ways better than
any human beings have in i mean founding
fathers giants historically in my view
because they came up with these truths i
do think they're truths but they're
certainly not self-evident i mean if
they were your arm is right they would
have discovered them thousands of years
earlier or or everybody would accept
them right i mean how many people today
think that those what they state in that
document is true
pretty much
you know five people i don't know it's
it's it's very it's very you're a
criticism of modern society it's get
there it's very very few people
recognize that if they were self-evident
bam everybody would have become uh
you know would have accepted the
american revolution as as truth and that
was it a lot of work has to go into
understanding and describing and
convincing people about those truths but
but i i completely disagree with your
arm about
uh this idea or i'll i'll voice my
dissents as we said you're this official
about about a the this being two
different revolutions and and b that the
american revolution was had any
similarity to the french revolution i i
i you you know that jefferson and payne
were that they were in france running
into running a different right now but
they but they
were waiting constantly i mean they were
in communication with madison there was
a lot of input going on i know and
jefferson's sitting there in paris
pulling his hair out because madison
madison has come under the influence of
these nationalists and he can't believe
it
the reality is that the difference
between the french revolution and and
the and the american revolution is is is
vast and it is a deep philosophical
difference and it's a difference it
expressed i think uh between the
differences that you know joram
in his writings lumps who sow with locke
and with voltaire and with others and
and i think
i i think that's wrong i think russo is
very different than the others i think
again russo is an anti-enlightenment
figure was so is a is in many respects
hawkening back to a past an ancient past
and i think and i think a completely
distorted view of human nature of human
mind he rejects reason i mean rousseau
is on the premise that reason is the end
of humanity reason is the destruction of
humanity reason is is how we get
civilization and civilization is awful
because i i i don't disagree we're only
talking about different texts
when i say i'm just talking about the
social contract yeah but the social
contract he there's similarity between
others but he takes it in a completely
different direction and we agree with
social context is a bad idea but it it
they can't have a contract that you
don't actually voluntarily accept
but so is the french revolution rousseau
is
about destruction and mayhem and chaos
and anarchy
he is the spirit behind the french
revolution i i think the american
revolution is a complete rejection of
rousseau uh i think jefferson is a
complete rejection of russo i don't
think jefferson is a fan of who so he is
of voltaire and he certainly is a
monastery if you look at it and if you
look at the federalist papers the the
intellectual most cited in the
federalist papers i think in terms of
just the number of times decide is
montesquieu you know so i think that the
american revolution is an
individualistic revolution
it is a revolution about the rights of
the individual the french revolution is
a negation of the rights of the
individual it's a collectivistic
revolution it's it's not quite
the marxist revolution of the
proletarian but it it's defining people
in classes
and it's a rebellion against a certain
class and and yeah
kill them all right off with their heads
and it is a negation uh it's about
egalitarianism in the sense of equality
of outcome not in a sense of equality
before the law or equality of rights
which is the jeffersonian sense so i
think it's it's it's wrong to to lump
jefferson in
to the uh fraternity uh you know
egalitarian notion of of the french
which is far more similar to
to what ultimately became socialism and
marxism
or in in
in kind of that tradition it's
anti-individualistic the french
revolution is whereas the american
revolution the first one uh is is
individualistic it's all about
individual rights and and while there's
certain phrases in the declaration of
independence that i don't
agree with you know it's beautifully
written and it's a magnificent document
so it's hard for me to say i don't agree
who am i right these were these were
giants uh
self-evident is one of them
you know i'm not particularly uh
crazy about endowed by the creator um
but i like the fact that it's creator
and not god or not a specific creator
but just it kind of a more general thing
but putting those two ashes aside it's
the greatest political document in all
of human history in my view by far
nothing comes close it it is it is a
document that that identifies the core
principles
of
political tourism of truth that is the
role of government is to preserve and to
protect these rights these inalienable
rights and and that is so crucial that
these rights are unalienable that is a
majority can't vote them out uh you know
revelation can't vote them out th this
is
this is what is required for human
liberty and human freedom the the right
that is the the the sanction the freedom
to act on your own behalf to act based
on your own judgment as and as long as
you're not
you know interfering with other people's
rights you are free to do so that is
such a profound truth and that to me is
the is the is is the essence of
political philosophy that's the
beginning you know and and it's it's
based on just just to not fall into you
i'm going to say uh it's a rationalist
it's based on a whole history of what
happens when we negate that it's based
on looking at england and seeing to the
extent that they practiced a respect for
individual liberty of property of of of
uh freedom good things happened
so let's take that all the way let's not
compromise on that let's let's be
consistent with the good and reject the
bad and when england goes away distance
itself from the rights of man from the
idea of of a right to property and so on
bad things happen and when they go
through let's go all in and i'm i'm all
in on on the right to life liberty
property in the pursuit of happiness and
i think the idea of pursuit of happiness
is profound because it's a mall
statement it's a statement that says
that sanctions and and and says that
ultimately people should be allowed to
make their own judgments and and live
their lives as they see fit based on how
they
view happiness they might be right they
might be wrong but we're not gonna
dictate what happiness entails and
dictate to people how they should live
their lives we're going to let them
let them figure that out so it has this
self-interested moral code kind of
embedded in it so i think it's a
beautiful statement so i think the
declaration is key and i i
i think there was an experiment and
experiment was per post
uh in that period of of uh before the
constitution where the experiment was
let's let the states let's have a kind
of a loose confederation uh let's let
the states experiment with with setting
up their own constitutions and role of
government and we won't have any kind of
unity and i think what they realized
and i think even jefferson realized is
that that was not workable because
many of the states were starting to
significantly violate rights there was
nothing to unify there was nothing to
really protect
the vision of the declaration you needed
to establish a nation which is what the
constitution does it establishes a
nation
but the purpose of that
was
to put everybody under one set
of laws that protected rights the the
the focus was still on the protection of
rights and i agree with six of the seven
of the principles right i and i and
which did disagree with the common
welfare which which the general was
trying to worry about right i think in
the way the founders understood it i
think i probably agreed with it
you